[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
open the pod bay doors yes
is
is really a wonderful and delightful
writer and a
fellow podcaster and author
a wonderful wonderful author of many
books books about dirac books about
churchill
books about
books about the universe and today we're
going to be talking about this book and
we're going to schedule you know five
more parts five more episodes of if
graham will beg me his forbearance or my
forbid i don't know which forbearance
but graham farmhello thank you so much
for joining us how are you today i'm
very well thank you for having me on
it's a pleasure
you know my motto of my channel is
always be curious abc
and i think i will title this episode uh
from newton to nema because we're going
to go from this little man here this is
supposed to be isaac newton a finger
puppet of isaac newton what
oh i see the one i'm sorry he looks like
einstein but he's holding newton yeah
yeah yeah i haven't i have an einstein
einstein is uh he's over there i'll get
einstein later but there's uh this is
isaac newton
he's not a good representation but nema
doesn't they don't uh have one for nema
just yet because these finger puppet
manufacturers they're a little bit
behind the time just a couple hundred
years or so so
i want to uh talk about the the universe
speaks in numbers there's a theme that
runs through it and i've been talking a
lot on my podcast into the impossible
about uh the difference of opinions as
to whether or not first of all we need a
theory of everything whether fear of
everything is a proper scientific
discipline and my first question to you
uh is sort of a pun but it's sort of a a
truth hidden within the pun and that's i
wonder graham sometimes are we putting
the uh the toe before the gut in other
words we don't have a grand unified
theory as far as i know that everybody
agrees upon and yet we're kind of
obsessed with the theory of everything
that unites all four forces you know we
don't really have a a very strong
inkling of how to unify the three
strongest forces what do you think about
this notion that we're obsessed with
kind of skipping the
gut and going straight to the toe
honestly
i think there's a danger here of uh over
dramatizing um
what uh what what physicists are
seeking to do
um i i must say straight away i mean i i
or like all authors you know uh
it's very tempting to go with these
brief acronyms and these you know these
big big ideas
uh and what have you but i i i i'm much
more comfortable myself with uh with a
if you like a planar statement
of uh what i believe physicists uh
theoretical businesses are seeking to do
with of course experimental
what what i think
we are seeking to do
is find a theory of the
most
fundamental uh interactions that we know
of in nature what do we mean by that i
mean interactions where we don't
uh we are don't know that they are built
from something
deeper so to speak in other words things
that we find as fundamental and the most
fundamental entities
that we can identify
now
uh
you could never put that on a t-shirt i
realize that but basically we're talking
about the uh you know the strong weak
electromagnetic interactions and the
thing that looks very different
superficially uh
which is gravity
now
physicists of that this kind of
persuasion
uh are very very focused on the uh
understanding the the smallest possible
the largest possible so the cosmos and
the very smallest but following my my
late friend phil anderson you all i
think it's it i really do think it's
important to bear in mind that you know
even if you have the standard model in
all its glory remember it's how
beautifully tested is you still can't
predict the shape of a cauliflower for
example
there are things you can't do with those
fundamental
theories uh and no one knows how to do
it because there are other principles
that other types of physicists uh look
at now i'm not i i do believe that there
is such a thing as uh you know a
fundamental branch of physics but i do
think it's important to have some
humility and bear in mind
that we're not talking about the whole
of physics here we're talking about
you know actually quite a small but in
my opinion very significant proportion
of the whole activity of physics
right so and and i think
that it it's
over
over playing it to think that uh that
that we have ever so or rather in
certainly in the immediate future come
up with a you know a theory that you can
write on a t-shirt or what have you that
from which everything else will plainly
follow i do i think that is
overselling it frankly
yeah i'm speaking of course about my
past guest michio kaku who's uh been on
the show and and is gracious and and
kind and as uh likes to talk and promote
the god equation and we can talk about
god of course as as isaac newton was
want to do and i love the quote that you
have in your book you know kind of a a
pertinent to sort of this notion that we
talk about nowadays the imposter
syndrome uh i did a podcast with barry
barrish not too long ago that inspired
my next book which is going to be called
the think like a nobel prize winner and
barry told me he had the imposter
syndrome uh once in his life and i said
uh you got to be kidding me you know
that that can't be anymore and he's like
no i feel it even more than ever because
when i got the nobel prize i had to sign
this log book saying i got the actual
golden medallion and i saw albert
einstein's name and i said i'm not
worthy and i said barry come on you must
know that he must have felt that
somebody else was you know his superior
probably isaac newton and in your book
and you know chapter two you point out
that uh albert einstein called uh you
know uh isaac newton basically the
greatest contributor to western culture
um you know uh in history and then and
then you go one step further and you say
isaac newton basically didn't speak
about what physicists were but he spoke
about god and he was sort of you know he
had imposter syndrome about jesus christ
almighty and it's just interesting to me
because you know the universe or god
speaks in numbers
and uh there's a quote by a
mathematician you know that um god
created the integers and all the rest is
mentioned verk uh i forget my father was
a mathematician he used to say things
like that to me um but my question to
you first of all is does does the
universe speak in integers or
real numbers irrational numbers what do
you think i've got to say here that uh
if if you uh
if i were a more ambitious person uh in
terms of just putting out exactly what i
mean
i would say
that
i was alluding there to a sentiment of
diracs which is that the universe speaks
in mathematics
right now i mean i ask for i ask for
your one's indulgence on this you may
not think that uh there's a big
difference what i'm trying what i'm
alluding to there is the idea
that
we
can learn about the universe not just
through
making observations on it but also there
is another
way of learning about it which is uh
through uh
mathematics
now it's very very important to
recognize that uh physics and
mathematics are not the same thing right
that is really really important right
the great majority of physicists right
are not involved in the world
of mathematics research per se and and
vice versa
um but
this is the point about uh about uh iraq
um
it he argued uh in his great 1939
lecture which we could talk we could
talk about here all day uh because it is
a phenomenon phenomenally insightful uh
lecture that if you look at these uh
what he would call the fundamental
theories of nature so he's thinking
about uh
quantum mechanics
theory of the very very small he's
talking about
einstein's theory of relativity of space
and time and gravity that each time
there is an advance
they are framed in terms of what what
iraq would say is more and more
beautiful mathematics now you don't need
to be a genius to say well paul what do
you mean by beautiful mathematics and
that's a fair question i don't think he
gives it a perfect answer to put it to
be uh to be honest he simply says well
if you don't know what that means right
i can't help you because mathematicians
know what that means and i'm going to
say with the greatest respect to the
iraq i mean i don't think that is a
is a water type definition but i
that said i still think it's a useful
idea
right whereby
you work with i
ideas of increasing mathematical uh
power you could say beauty universality
and all the things that beauty entails
and
it can be uh
in the right hands iraq's uh and
other great physicists einstein in
particular had similar views which we
could talk about
mathematics could be a load star which
guides you in the right direction
let me be clear
that just working on mathematics will
not get you to uh your most ambitious
theories just working on that it takes
an enormous amount of skill and judgment
in order to bring together both of those
things very very few people could
couldn't do that and the problem is
today
uh that has been a theme of your podcast
but maybe not stated always
very explicitly but we're in a very very
odd time at the moment in the kind of
physics we're talking about because we
found to our
you could say consternation of
physicists that
the standard model of the subatomic uh
forces
looks much much better than we ever
dreamed it it would do so much better
that the this incredible machine that
our experimentalist friends have
brilliantly made has really only given
us so far uh what uh
he's gifted us
a uh proof so to speak of the existence
of the higgs particle the last brick in
the the wall so to speak of the standard
model but it uh to at the amazement of
people it hasn't shown up these extra uh
this this richer structure or higher
energies
so
uh
it it that is why very broadly speaking
without those clues which we so yearned
for
right
that many leading physicists including
nemes one of them many others um
are
are working on parts of physics where
they're guided as well as what we
already know by beautiful
mathematics
now let me just say it'd be much better
let me let me i've often i've said in
what reviews before people you know if
if we had a choice it's a silly thing to
say but you'll know what i'm i'm getting
at you know if we had a choice now
between another einstein or you know
another rutherford right we take the
rutherford because
but you know i think most physicists
would say it's been very
disappointing saddening
nemo let him speak for himself but i
think he'd say no we laid that nature is
telling you something you've got to be
smart right um but we're in a difficult
place i can't remember a time like this
it's the beginning of theoretical
physics where you know so many elite
physicists are that are struggling to
know which way to proceed and that's why
there's been this culture now of
naysayers coming out saying no you're
all the br all the best people are all
getting it all wrong right
that gap has been left uh has been
filled by by these uh um outriders
and i wonder you know from the
experimentalist point of view first of
all i thank you and i'll i'll then mow
you some cash for the plug for
experimental physics uh first of all
we're looking toward the heavens now and
i wonder you know what what you would
make of it or what theorist would make
of it you know if for the very first
time in history
uh a cosmologist or an astronomer would
tell an elementary particle physicist
the mass of a fundamental particle like
the neutrino that seems to be catrin
just came out with an upper limit of
order the electron volt
for the mass sum total of neutrinos and
where i'm like welcome tonight you know
to 2005 and the cosmic microwave
background uh no congratulations to them
it's a wonderful laboratory-based result
incredibly painstaking
uh but you know we're far ahead of that
we're in the you know milli electron
volt you know hundreds of milli electron
volt regime and we're going to do better
with simon's observatory and and cosmic
microwave background experiments to come
but uh when i say when i hear uh
experiment theorists kind of do things
like well we need a future experimental
uh collider or something like that to
test my theory of everything be it uh my
friend eric weinstein or um uh loop
quantum gravity in the form of carlo
revelli who's been on the show or elise
mullin or you know any of these folks or
or you know nemo when he comes on the
show i often say well you know imagine
if i had went back you know 20 years ago
graham and i said to you um well how
about this i can't build you a bigger
better large hadron collider just yet
but i can smash together 230 solar mass
objects uh comprised of you know pure
neutronic you know material at at half
the speed of light and i can do that uh
you know and i can i can do that and i
can record that many many times and i
can give you you know an atom smasher
that smashes together you know 10 to the
59th atoms of pure hadronic material how
about that you know can you can you make
uh some predictions is what your theory
would say and and they all say well you
know in other words what when newton was
thinking about the unification of color
theory you know he could go in and and
blank out parts of the of the spectrum
and he could look at the low energy
limit and and he could use that later to
think about unification how come
theorists are not thinking about the low
energy limit as as a clue to what the
high energy frontier might yield could
we even approach it
well
i take your point that uh steve weinberg
once commented to me that you know the
new uh you know the frontiers at the
moment look like they're in in
astrophysics and cosmology with all
these incredible results like the
increasing acceleration of the uh
universe what what a result that was
nobody ordered that
i
i'm afraid i'm old enough to remember
when the standard model was being uh
basically formed um
you know with you know with weinberg you
will check to grosses and or many many
other people uh there
and it was a incredible experience it
really was an incredible experience to
me you know i i remember for example
people
saying uh well i could give you several
examples with one
not in the standard model but i remember
ron drever
did my first academic job coming and
giving a talk
and people laughing at the thought of
detecting gravitational waves
right
i can remember very clearly uh meetings
at the royal society where people were
saying that the
third lepton right well you know come on
you know you know but marty paul wants a
nobel prize and what have you all right
and we know what happened right um
so yeah
i've seen this
where people and of course i remember
when reading about rudy pyles where he
he was one of the great theories of the
war years and
soon afterwards saying that you know
what no one's actually going to detect
the neutrino you know i mean that that's
just not going to be on and that's why i
i'm reluctant ever to say that we'll
never be able to test this we never be
able to do these very high energy
experiments because you know you never
know what is around the corner yeah um
so one of my uh heroes and friends that
i'm blessed to know is jim simons who
plays a very uh important role in this
book i've tried to get frank yang on the
podcast as well uh he's he's quite
elderly as you know uh and you describe
in the book um uh and the book is is so
delightful you describe the role of
frank and jim simons uh as sort of this
interesting role that i believe is sort
of echoed later although amplified
certainly by ed whitton it's sort of a
catalyst you know bridging together the
you know the the older generation in the
in the form of the rack and maybe with
with uh genetic material in some sense
of of maxwell and then literally in the
form of yang and mills you know
basically on steroids the the maxwell
equations uh and then and then later you
know inculcating it with with the chern
simons can you say something about you
know where is whitten in all this now uh
of course you know with with large you
know nowadays i see him on on you know
twitter and and so forth and he's he's
talking about israel you know basically
all the time i'm
i'm wondering where is he getting any
time to to to you know to do any string
theory or any work but i haven't seen
and his most recent papers are about
maybe planet nine is a black hole has he
given up i mean what what's going on
with with whitten these days and is
anyone playing the catalytic role that
he once played or jim simons has play uh
once played well i think
again i i feel a little bit i've got to
answer your question out of courtesy but
yeah i feel a bit bad
speculating on what uh what edward is
doing i will say that he is
very carefully spoken he knows about the
people like me and i just say your good
self take a lot of notice on my podcast
when i put that one out it practically
broke it broke my server yeah
everybody listened to exactly and it is
really worth listening i mean to quote
weinberg edward is deep deep deep
right
he doesn't throw around these words uh
these big and i i think i know people we
want that from the leaders the
preeminent people in our field but he's
very very careful i certainly have heard
him say right uh that i in picking up
the point we discussed uh just a few
minutes ago you know it's diffic
it's difficult to know what to do in the
in the face of what we're seeing at the
lhc right um now that's not because
people like him are not brilliant it's
because it's not
we really weren't ready for
that uh for this outcome of outcoming
perhaps a wrong word but the findings of
the large hadron collider it maybe it's
all going to win maybe
something's going to show up next week
but at the moment it really it's
starting to look like we're not going to
be finding these uh you know these
wonderful things uh phenomena that we
were hoping for uh i remember
incidentally there's one little thing
before i come back to wadewood that i
was uh one of the people that worked on
the draft of the um
the public relations strategy of the
large hadron collider
and i was yeah for the folder for the
british research council and i was
looking at that document the other day
right it's an internal document and it
but we canvassed uh the very best
physicist asked what they were expecting
for the large effort collider right
and uh i have to say i think we broke
down something like it was something
like a dozen things that we that like
you know large new large extra
dimensions symmetry of course uh right
and yeah
what did we what have we found we found
that the higgs particle yeah and that's
it that's it right now
please i probably experiment here this
is absolutely not to put down the
fantastic experimental work that has
been done to get those things but my
goodness gracious we really did uh it
so far
maybe things changed next week but so
far you know uh we we really have got
very little out of additional value out
of it um
now
i i think going back to edward i said as
i said with apologies to him if he ever
hears this like people like me shouldn't
be summarizing what hitton says but i
suspect he's saying i don't
have a useful suggestion about what to
do next right he what he did say to me
in my podcast i treasure the quote
because he is so powerful that i asked
him right about uh you know whether he
sought string theory
that i mean m theory by that but the
generalized spring theory right uh about
other options
and he said right and i remember very
carefully listening so carefully
is that string theory is the only
interesting generalization of yang mills
uh
quantum field theory
all right now if i were working on loop
quantum gravity which he just says is
just words
right i'd be very very worried right
he's the last person in the world you
would you regard as a fool in these
things the last person in the world
right that you would regard as somebody
who's a simplistic thinker but i think
that that was that to me is quite
important
he because he's saying that uh something
that you hear from many experts
not not i don't think he would use these
same words but many people when i was
writing the universe pixel numbers who
were saying to me the biggest problem we
have right with string theories we just
don't fully understand it
right they certainly don't want to write
it off they know it's got serious
problems of course but it's the best the
only option we interesting option that
we that we have right but that said uh
you i i do think it's fair to say in all
generosity uh right that uh
after the incredible fanfare that the
string string theory had in the 80s when
it you know with the first string
revolution the second one where edward
did that incredible work and then with
the uh that developed in the late 90s
it's
very difficult
to
identify in a clear communicable way the
progress that we're making with that
field not to say you throw it away but
it's not easy to uh
to happen to say well we solve this
problem this problem basically
everything is sorted out
so
that's why i think we're in a difficult
position on this
yeah i agree and and to that extent i
feel there is some glibness on the part
of folks like
michio kaku who will you know rightfully
say that he is the father of you know
string field theory and he wrote down
some of the first you know feynman
diagrams in the early 70s and i reviewed
those on the interview i did with him
but then he'll go i'll turn around and
say if we get this uh we'll know the
mind of god and your countryman stephen
hawking also was no stranger to
hyperbole about string theory m theory
even to the point of conceding bets uh
willy nilly you know i wish i i did meet
him once i heard him speak once uh and
that was wonderful at a royal society
meeting in 1995. i'll treasure that well
i heard about that and you're really a
podcast yeah yeah uh but uh but the the
fact is he would always concede these
bets uh long before i think you know he
should have maybe it was for the
publicity of conceding bet you know
steven's concedes about because they
were conceited on the basis of you know
calculations in five-dimensional ads cft
by juan maldasena or something you know
which is you know so far removed from
any kind of experimental verification i
mean i think it's you know as as some
have said it's it's impossible to to you
know deny that it could be that black
holes uh preserve information but you
can't necessarily confirm it so uh
fellow guest uh
leonard suskin has said you know this is
this is my battle to preserve quantum
mechanics well who knows but but when
michio says things like this the mind of
god and quotes that at the end of his
book
um i i think it does a disservice
because ultimately
beauty as ed is saying implicit is is
subjective and as uh he's saying it's
interesting that's a euphemism for
beauty or you know there's something uh
that peaks his fancy and as my namesake
uh the poet keats said beauty is truth
truth beauty that is all ye need no on
earth and all ye need to know
uh and actually dirac you know echoed
that the only time i think that he used
the uh referred to god he was not a
religious man by any means as you know
uh he said god is a mathematician of a
very high order as
you've you've said this graham so you
know this but i'm saying for my
listeners who may not know graham's
wonderful you know words on dirac and i
recommend it uh god is a mathematician
of a very high order and he used very
advanced mathematics in constructing the
universe so um i i think it's
interesting that we do this but we also
don't necessarily
have a rubric or a criteria set
for how do we judge these theories how
do we you know beauty is is one thing
but i don't know if you've ever seen
this gram
but they've done studies on who is
handsome who is beautiful so they take
um they take brad pitt so he's
reputedly the most handsome man on earth
okay present company excluded okay grant
so they'll take brad pitt but then
they'll say
they've done so they'll take his face
and they'll divide it down the middle
they'll take a picture of him and then
the mirror image will reflect his left
side to his right side and then that'll
be a new face he looks grotesque he
looks hideous nobody wants to look at it
and he'll be the ugliest man on earth so
symmetry is ugly and actually it's the
broken symmetry that we find beautif
beautiful and allows us to live as you
point out in this book you know the the
the broken symmetry is what's actually
beautiful about the world if perfect
symmetry would be perfect uh you know
entropy we wouldn't exist so we would
have equilibrium so um so so why is it
that beauty i don't think beauty should
necessarily be a condition of uh it
might work for keats and poetry but not
necessarily for physics so what what do
you make of this should we have a rubric
that we apply at the end of your book
you come up with six ideas that you
think will stand the test of time from
our modern era but let's start right now
what kind of a rubric could we put forth
for grading candidate theories of
everything what what would count what
would you put in such a rubric
wow
that's a good it's a good question it's
a pretty talent let me just i'll come
back to it i promise yeah sure come and
get back to me i just wanted to say that
i think the mind of god when i read that
sentence in uh hawking's book
uh i thought that's an inspired uh last
line and you're an author i bet
as an author you would know what right
because somehow it has a kind of it's uh
it's poetic
um and it's a metaphor right it is
absolutely of course it is not a literal
statement right correct now uh i simply
say that by over using it uh uh it is it
is actually
borderline silly frankly to try to make
that more than it is right i think most
people even if they're not physicists
if you describe to them basically what
physicists are trying to do
understanding these different
interactions in terms of mathematical
theories if you have a theory you can
explain all these people know yeah i get
what you mean it's it's somehow it you
know it's it's a satisfying way of
summarizing it but to try to talk about
that as a designer
right to me is uh
well you wouldn't get any questions
you really wouldn't now in terms of the
the progress we make
right the first thing is uh uh
not to be at uh sniff that in my view
right you absolutely must genera uh in
the standard way in science you have to
generate
all the successful predictions right
that have been uh made by theories
before
now and that
that
that is why
the essential guide rails of people
working in this field are quantum
mechanics and
relativity
right now it it it's something that i've
tried to
emphasize in that book perhaps i didn't
do it enough right
because it's still not spoken about
enough in my opinion
is
that
if i were asked right what is the
central lesson of the late 20th century
theoretical physics i would say it is
the astonishing power right of yoking
together what looked like the uh the
most unlikely of bedfellows which are
relativity and quantum mechanics they
look completely different mathematically
they are different of nature we know
that one's a classical theory one of
those is quantum they're not the same
thing
and if you do something right
as bold as to try to bring them together
right and iraq i believe was the first
person to start on that road many others
worked on that right then
the
key thing is to say that if you want to
send out a quantum field theory of the
interaction between charged particles
like electrons and photons for example
right it's steve weinberg stresses in
his quantum field theory book it's
incredibly difficult to do it really is
only just possible now that's a really
important thing to understand it's not
just a question this is easy to bring
these two things together right it's
extremely difficult it's almost like
you're you're going on a a razor's edge
so to speak and yet that theory right uh
you're talking about here dirac and
heisenberg and several other authors
then made usable by dyson schwinger
feynman tommenaga right
that theory is 18 decimal places right
now that is telling you something right
it is saying that these two improvable
theories were brought together and
putting you in the right direction
and you look at the other uh great great
successes of those two things of course
the direct prediction of the
anti-electoral or the anti-matter came
out of quantum mechanics and relativity
right hawking's greatest triumph came
from taking general relativity and
brilliantly uh working with in a way
that doesn't actually isn't actually a
unification but is a if you're like a
jamming together ingenious jamming
together of quantum mechanics and uh an
einstein's theory of gravity and of
course
the modern uh quantum field theory of
all the subatomic forces they're all
based on those things and they that that
is incredibly difficult to do it's
something that as i said i don't think
it expressed nearly enough that
physicists don't just sit down and write
any old theories down they have to stick
to those that those
the these two um
giant foundations though
right yeah as nema says it's very hard
to break the standard model of quantum
mechanics absolutely right actually i
use that gram that's part of my rubric
so i look for you know i study you know
the cosmic microwave background and
within that i used to think the greatest
trophy of all would be gravitational
waves and detecting b mode polarization
from the putative inflationary origin of
the universe of course i wouldn't turn
that down and some say been there done
that uh of course we had to retract and
we can't as you know uh i'm better than
anyone probably besides me this would
cause great sensation but the um
but the quest that really
motivates me now
is the search potentially for small
departures from our most sure symmetries
lorenzen variants perhaps primordial
magnetism phase transitions these are
ways that we can and nima's words break
the standard model but they must be
subtle they must be subtle but maybe as
the lord is not malicious right
so so those are you know it's very hard
to do and that is part of the rubric
that i think becomes very hard to so
we're the low-hanging fruit has been
picked and and and so we're left with
beating our head and grinding our head
against granite but but i i guess you
know the question becomes
are there low energy ways so the cmb is
a low energy phenomenon it's you know
three kelvin photons but they trace the
properties potentially of a very high
energy phenomenon and that's what makes
it interesting to me so
my hope is that are there other you know
ways that we can look machine learning
you know either exoplanet i don't know
there's some signature using cosmic data
perhaps or laboratory data
microgravity scales to test um to test
you know departures from the standard
model indicative to grade these theories
because when i talk to mitchie or i talk
to proponents of string theory they say
things like well you know um
how is it possible that you know like
when i complain about the multiverse
aspects of of string theory well you
know how many solutions are there in
maxwell's equations there's an infinite
number you have to tell us the the you
know the boundary conditions the initial
conditions okay well i can tell you
boundary conditions from physical
observation but you can't retrodict and
use that as a prediction for example g
minus two results came out lhcp resulted
yeah he was claiming those are those are
come as results of string theory i said
come on how can that be
how can that be you can't you can't
claim everything right and you can't
simultaneously say you have to tell me
the vacuum state why is that my job as
the experimentalist shouldn't that be
the outcome of the of the theory
no i i i well
to me
you know i i
the more i look at the history of this
this subject i i really commend the
position of the conservative
revolutionary
right and then we start off with the
first
theoretical physicist i mean i know
that's a subjective matter but a very
good choice for that is max planck
right and uh i i admit i mean this is
being fanciful i accept that except that
but i
will always be fascinated with this
extremely conservative physicist right
who was you know told by his supervisor
i believe was that you know there's
nothing to be uh
learned now in physics basically we've
got the basic rules
he took what is a good a good
um
is a very good example of the most
dramatic uh step right in proposing that
radiation is uh comes in quanta right
and uh to quote uh bran plays right the
mathematics of doing that was mad
right i mean even if even if you're a
you know a a party
passable college student right a physic
could see that basically it pretty much
made no sense right but he was right
right and it took einstein then to take
it on another step forward and
beautifully clarify what what he meant
by that
this is the point where i'm going to
speculate uh and
like most speculation is probably wrong
but i'll be using your views on it that
you know i just wonder whether we're
missing
something some insight
right that uh that that is as radical as
uh a revolutionary right as that
contribution of planks was it yeah is
all this confusion could it be resolved
i'm not saying in a price but are we
missing something really uh really big
right now
obviously it may be nonsense but i just
wonder you know the state we're in
whether we are just missing something i
was thinking about that as i was reading
it and just i couldn't help but but uh
you know just just imagine the the
amount of you know obviously progress is
usually there's a paper called progress
by compression uh it's a wonderful paper
and one of the culminations of it is you
know think about how much compression is
involved in einstein's e equals m c
squared like how much information how
much notions about reality are
compressed into that and i think that's
true and then of course think of how
many books are needed to explain what is
the meaning of that then it's like
expansion but but now think the opposite
way graham think like 1901 plank you
know 1900 1901 plank nobel prize for you
know a three symbol equation you know
equals h nu or equals hf or uh you know
and then and then einstein later you
know his no he didn't win the nobel
prize for it but but e equals mc squared
four symbols you know and now it's like
nema and and and his colleague it's like
a hundred pages
of mathematical formulae and i'm
wondering like is this going in the
right direction or is that just a symbol
that the low-hanging fruit have been
picked
and um and it is curious to me you know
is i can't tell i i don't know when i
look at things so i i do like to ask my
my the people that like the kaku's
because i do think that he has
interesting insights so i said to him
here's um here here are some interesting
arguments from critics of string theory
lee smullin carlo revelli and um and and
by the way these are people that you
don't necessarily agree with do you
believe that the tradition yeah
yeah but you uh but but the but you're
you know you're obviously um you get
along and and you don't you don't um
necessarily um uh there's no hard
feelings you're just criticizing no no
no yeah but um but michio is much more
aggressive i think he's saying well look
there's nothing in their theory they
don't even have fermions you know
they're they're doing something maybe
it's gravity but it's not a theory of
everything the way string theory is
string theory can give you you know the
elephant and it can wiggle its tail a
string theory can give you the one inch
equation it can give you uh even
mathematics and and my thing to him was
well can it can it do over much you know
can it can because of this vacuum
problem is there not a danger that um
that that you know the laws of physics
might be different in each one of these
landscape universes but maybe the laws
of logic maybe the laws of mathematics
in other words how is it that you're
guaranteed to have a self-consistent
form you know modus tollens is it going
to agree in a universal landscape where
even you know even these dimensions we
don't necessarily have evidence that
they agree and he couldn't really answer
that except to say that in string theory
you know you get gravity out naturally
but again i said we don't have evidence
for these large dimensions and so my
question is is it is it not already
falsified and his basic response is it's
too early to say that and all the other
candidate theories as whitten would say
are uninteresting and if not um uh if
not already wrong
well i i do think uh
personally i uh i respect him his point
of view and his his heart's in the right
place but i do think that it's almost
he's almost like he's in the 80s where
you know where that that
sense of almost triumphalism in uh
string theory but it it to say that now
when there are so many uh
challenges besetting the theory
you can't really blame people for being
skeptical right because you know i mean
i i know this might sound naive but in
the end you know the plain person is
gonna wanna know right why should i
believe in this right yes yes um now uh
that i do think we owe
people who are not physicists at least
you know indications of why we take
string theory seriously and as i said
that quote of edwards it's the most
interesting generalization of a of a
obviously successful gangfield's field
theory at least
at least that is at least clear about
what it is but there are so many things
that
that that string three uh hasn't done
for example it hasn't retro explained
things you know there you i don't think
i think i'm right in saying that you
can't
take problems in in the physics of
fundamental particles that were that
were explained by string theory
backwards so to speak right steve
weinberg registered and that he's like
that's my understanding of it when i
spoke to him about that about this so
you know i i
i think you know you know i think
there's a cultural thing here at bryant
because you know we're in an age
where every everyone can be an expert
for assault everyone can have a view on
anything right and i'm as i mentioned at
the end of my book i don't wish to be
mean spirited but you know i think that
you know that we've lost this deference
for uh authority uh yeah authority and i
don't just mean that we should worship
the top you know the the
most famous professor or what have you
no we shouldn't right but i think we
should have at least a respect for why
parts of the community are spending so
much time on that and i think there is
another point if i could just be
critical uh for a second i i think
personally it's regrettable
that
a sober
thoughtful response from string
theorists to these critics isn't more
forthcoming i think that's a real shame
i i think i know why they do it
incidentally although i'm not going to
name any names
it's like the dork richard dawkins
when he when he stopped talking to
creationists right right and that was
because he said you simply can't win
you simply can't win now i still think
uh maybe i'm old-fashioned uh but i
think
that there is uh that there is plenty of
room for uh for a small number of forums
where the people who uh
you know the people who are very
doubtful about the way that um
spring theory is going could talk to
their critics in a way now it's not easy
to do i let me say this is not a trivial
thing but at the moment i see very few
examples of where uh uh
uh very articulate people on the public
say like sabina for example like lee and
what have you actually talk in a
respectful straightforward way right he
said it's done through intermediaries
you know right or on twitter or twitter
and i i don't think that's ever i tell
you i honestly can't think it maybe it
may be my ignorance but i thought a fair
bit about this i can't think of another
stage in physics where it's been where
it's been like that i really can't
right and nor can i think of a time that
mates related where people who the
community of theoreticians would say are
the world's leading people are just
routinely dissed right as if well they
just don't know what they're talking
about right i mean
incredible situation right again again
i'm reading your book and i just love
this book so much graeme i want to just
re reset the uh conversation for a
second this is the universe speaks in
numbers graeme varmelo uh who's just a
delight to speak to the author of
several books strangest man about paul
dirac who we'll have back on again that
one the los angeles times book prize
is a fellow at the churchill college at
the university of cambridge's book about
churchill the bomb uh churchill's a
fascinating character i love winston
churchill my nine-year-old ten-year-old
was reading uh his thousand-page auto
biography recently tell your
nine-year-old to read hawking
sorry that's my present project i'm
sorry about that um but uh being your
father but uh yeah uh uh
uh churchill's best book which was
actually alluded to in his nobel
citation was a book your nine-year-old
could read called my early life
okay a nine-year-old could read it's a
charming book and it's about his youth
i can't wait i i
it's an easy it's a lovely read and i
say again the no bill people uh had that
in mind when they gave that when they
gave his prize i will certainly refer
that to him and uh and then of course he
was a uh he is a regular visitor at the
institute for advanced studies in
non-pandemic times i assume and he will
get back there and i will hopefully have
him someday graham you'll come and visit
me in san diego where this office used
to be occupied by jeff burbidge oh and
margaret burbidge uh we'll talk a little
bit about that that segues nicely maybe
perhaps into the conversation we're just
talking about these weird times that we
live in and i was thinking you know you
talk in the book about these about
maxwell and uh and and how you know he
came up with this mechanical model of
how light would propagate and he used
these gears and wheels and vortices and
stuff and can you imagine uh what would
have happened if twitter were around
back then you know
he would have had this you know hashtag
trending you know this fool you know
these gears you know this idiot thinks
the scottish scotsman that's actually
that's a that is a really good point
actually it's a really good topic
because if you if you look at the
classic article that maxwell wrote which
i spent a few pages in the universe but
about the relationship between physics
and mathematics he talks about a theory
of electromagnetism he doesn't say i'm
i'm the only one who's right no
everybody else is wrong all those german
guys don't know what they're talking
about he's and he he turned out to be
right the poor guy was dead before we
knew that right he died so
you raised a good point there but you
know if twitter had been around there i
know that this is a you know what i call
it bending reality but you know people
simply said all right it's uh it's a
it's a theory that maxwell has got here
he is a brilliant theoretician remember
he wasn't a physicist that never became
a physicist he called himself a natural
philosopher or a mathematical
philosopher but yes
but it was not this uh you know this
this bum fight so to speak uh right
about that and that's an example of even
what karl popper you know who's i always
say that physicists you know just as a
biologist have physics envy
and uh and it has said uh i believe that
physicists have you know girdle envy or
mathematician envy because we can't you
know really bound what we can't prove so
you know popper kind of substitutes
falsification demarcation hypotheses
substitutes for uh for d for uh girdles
uh incompleteness theorem but uh but
even popper himself said there is a
place for the uh for the uh you know
unfalsifiable because there is there
there is room uh for the development of
a known wrong theory to kind of blossom
and bloom because if nothing else it
sharpens the correct eventual emergent
theory and then that took place in this
very room with jeff burbidge and the
quasi-steady state theory which
prevailed as you probably know you know
the the companion paper that dickey
people's role and wilkinson put out to
the pension wilson paper doesn't mention
the big bang at all it mentions a cyclic
you know collapsing universe basically
as the origin of the thermal relic you
know background it doesn't mention the
big bang and obviously we don't believe
that to be the case uh and so too with
maxwell if people had you know so
this is ridiculous vortices are you know
so maybe right now we're you know some
of my colleagues and even i on occasion
will be too quick to sacrifice string
theory on the altar of a falsifiability
currently but i think you know the
challenge that i have as an
experimentalist is there's only so many
resources and again you know michio's
not here to defend himself but i said if
you're the head of the nsf there's only
so many dollars to go around there's
only so many postdocs to go around and
it's not fair to a young person you know
when they might get their first research
grant you know at age 41 or 42 here in
the u.s i don't know how it works in the
uk but it's very challenging very
competitive it's a bloodthirsty race
here but to get it very few positions
400 applicants for one job maybe at a
place like uc san diego and uh and you
get um you know it's a very long delayed
gratification so what are you going to
tell them michio should we should we let
loop quantum gravity and string theory
should we give equal amounts of money
what about to experiment and he's like
yeah just give equal amounts of money
and
i don't know i mean if if where where
you know how do you divide up finite
resources how do you engage you know the
community so that young people have
something productive to do do we have
too many people doing string theory i
mean eric weinstein has said that
explicitly and
and you should know he's a big fan of
yours um but but you know he said
explicitly we there's too many people
it's sucking the life out of it and you
probably heard the interview and at
least
i must say on that one uh that
i i i i'm not involved in these hiring
committee things but i've heard enough
people from freeman dyson to martin
reese and other people
it's a widespread view that um
it's a very very tough field
uh string theory and uh i i think there
is a case that
uh that you can never be sure you're
never sure when you when you fund
research but i i i if you are the
proportion of people working on that
field right is it too high then i
suspect it might be right because you
know you really have to be you know very
advanced mathematically as well as have
physical
and you are working with these constant
problems of
of observation and experiment so i i i
don't want to be disloyal to my string
theory friends but i do i think you have
a point too
you know you never know
it's very very difficult to know what to
invest money into in
in physics i've certainly persuaded that
we need another accelerator to study
study the higgs much more carefully but
that said you know i appreciate the
difficulty
because governments funding agencies
they want to see you know uh bang for
their bucks and
you know out of the large hadron
collider they've had one bang you know
to put it very crudely right now that
let me be very clear i definitely
invested that accelerator but you know
we have to be real even feynman i know
you see my research the university
speaks at
universe pixel numbers even he said
which i think is right it's a depressing
thought but we have to face it it may it
may be that we one day we run out of
money to do uh uh to do these high
energy experiments i'm sorry if that
depresses people but he's in the
environment's a great great physicist
and i don't think it's an unreasonable
thing to worry about right but
nonetheless it's too early to think like
that in my opinion
yeah i've often thought about that as as
my role as an experimentalist is kind of
being like galileo's assayer you know to
to kind of
to look through and and to and to see
what low-hanging
fruit might remain and it might be in
and that might be our
as you talk about at the end of the book
our silicon friends are you know the
artificial physicist so i've started a
project very slowly going called galil
aio where i'm trying to you know program
the works uh of galileo the text of his
books he wrote millions of words and
dumped them into a general ai program
and and try to you know teach it very
slowly quantum mechanics and so forth
over the years and see what pops out of
the great mind because he was uh
certainly a unique a a unique uh
intellect and i want to close out with
two unique intellects uh one of whom i
had on the podcast uh before he passed
away and that was my friend freeman
dyson oh girl you had freeman oh great
yes many times he was my first guest on
the theme possible podcast let's talk
about freeman uh what did he mean to you
you you talk about him so uh he was sort
of this voice of reason i want to relay
a quote to you
he and i talked about in in and it's
kind of an animating quote in my life
inside and outside of physics and it was
about god we were talking about god and
religion and and he kind of called
himself a an agnostic and and i used to
chide him about that you know he's such
a lovable person and and one of my
favorite memories is to is to uh as we'd
have him over for shabbat dinner you
know we're jewish and and he'd come over
and then my my now eight-year-old you
know is basically 90 years younger than
freeman and imna
and uh they would talk and it was just
funny seeing like nine decades
difference and they would just like have
these really interesting conversations
and uh and at one point i said to him
you know well you know freeman why do
you why do you have this interest in
religion why don't you just either not
go or not say you're an atheist because
you don't go to church like you don't go
to the same church that richard dawkins
doesn't go to so like why don't you just
call yourself an atheist and he's like
well you know there are things in life
that are mysteries and there are things
in life that are puzzles and you know to
me puzzles can be solved you know you
might not be able to solve them but
there are solutions and somebody's
smarter than me or smarter than you can
solve them uh but then there are
mysteries and mysteries may not have a
solution but that doesn't stop me from
wrestling with them and so my goal in
life i've started to think about like my
goal is to turn as many mysteries into
puzzles as possible like that's kind of
my mission statement and i want to ask
you like what like mysteries are are you
most engaged with now you you talked
about working on a on a book about
stephen hawking i'm really curious and
of course i'll invite you back in a
heartbeat to talk about that but what
mysteries and what did freeman mean to
you uh personally and then we'll close
out by talking about nema i can't resist
well uh
freeman i
when you say get to know i've got to
know him well i uh i'm not sure anyone
really understood uh friedman but uh he
was an incredible character and i i
i
spent dozens and dozens of hours talking
to him um
he
first thing to say right is to actually
let him describe himself right i've
written a um a remembering freeman dyson
article on my website i wrote just a few
days after he died and i'm sure i began
with this but he he said to me
and he said he said it elsewhere that he
was only good at two things which is uh
solving problems and writing essays
now i you know i scoffed uh right i
think forgivably right and and he said
and i said
something like that that's that's
ridiculous or something like that he
said it may sound religious but it's
true i remember him actually saying that
right um and he
he
he was a quite a superb mathematical
physicist make no mistake and a
brilliant um
my probably my favorite writer
right
in physics i mean the most silken style
right um so he he meant a a lot
to me he
i i do admit i found it frustrating
sometimes with his uh contrarianism
right he definitely had that right
i i have got a kind of amateur theory
here that i think he was so smart
um
freeman that he it would be because
most people he met including all these
other luminaries in physics
he could find a way around what they
were saying right so he it was almost a
game to him to say for example that uh
churchill was the second best leader
britain had in the wartime who's the
best freeman oh neville chamberlain
oh there are dozens of others like that
right and he would then hit you with the
thing that you hadn't thought of a new
perspective right
um with uh string
what was particularly interesting i
thought was in his approach to physics
right he thought the large hadron
collider was not a good use of money he
thought there were far too many people
working in string theory
he was always looking to provoke right
he loved that right and he uh
in princeton there's a statement you
often hear in the princeton community
right is namely that that freeman would
rather be interesting than right
that i think is very perceptive
right yeah he like he like the the you
know
the game of conversation i i really
believe that's a profound thing to say
about him you know he wants it to be
interesting right
ever being right you know that's a
that's a difficult
thing for him
what was your other question about about
you asked about oh yeah but it'll be
about nema but before we move on to that
i do want to say um so when i was
writing my book you know i didn't know
if i was going to write any more books
and i want to get some star power blurbs
on the back of the book and so i asked
freeman and it was right after my um my
third child was born my daughter my
first daughter
and i wrote for him and i said dear
freeman can you please um do me the
honor of writing a blurb for this book
it's about the losing the nobel prize
you know a subject that yeah i thought
he'd have some strong opinions about i
said dear brian congratulations on
getting the book done of my love to your
daughter orly my problem with blurbs is
that i have a strict rule not to write
blurbs unless i have actually read the
book yeah that's fine you told me that
and i already have a big pile of unread
books the idea is that a blurb is
supposed to be an honest expression of
information for the reader not just a
favor for the writer
perhaps it's a silly old-fashioned idea
anyway
i hope the book does well without my
help yours forever i mean absolutely
classic freeman
and you know what i've used that and so
now as you have done and i have done
after you write a book you get asked to
write blurs for people's books so i got
asked to write blurbs for books after my
book and i got a book in the mail just
about uh
back in early december and it was a book
it was about this thick
about eight 590 pages long and it was by
about intelligent design but it was by a
cambridge man by the name of uh steven
meyer and he's a phd in philosophy from
cambridge and he writes about
intelligent design and i've heard of him
before and he written me would would
would you do me the honor of writing a
blurb about this book called the return
of the god hypothesis
it's about entropy and and so forth and
i'll put links to that in the in the
show notes and whatever and i said uh
and he said um and could you could you
do the blurb by next week
what kidding me
so i said to him look steven i i i like
the idea but um but i have this rule
that i inherited from my friend the late
great freeman dyson so freeman has got
me out of a lot of sticky palavers as
you might say over there across the pond
um the last question i have is about um
is about nima and he figures very
prominently in the book and does provide
a so-called blurb on the back of the
book
and uh he is the you know after you is
the most requested guest on the into the
impossible podcast he calls this book uh
the universe speaks in numbers a
riveting account of one of the greatest
stories of our time graham formula has
delved in deep into this fascinating
subject combining original scholarship
and lively interviews with contemporary
theorists at its forefront of the field
the result is a masterful book which
gives us for the first time a
behind-the-scenes look at physicists and
mathematicians driven by the pursuit of
the ultimate truth capital t
have been drawn into the common
territory by their mysterious
intellectual forces seemingly beyond
their control okay his his blurb kind of
i'm going to encourage him to write a
book
he insisted on that capital t when that
is when my when my publishers say no
it's got to be he said no i want capital
i want to tie you know him and this um
and this in this capital t because it
kind of brought up something a beautiful
sentence that you kind of maybe put off
you know maybe it was a throwaway line
but it stuck out to me like a like a
phone call during uh during a glass of
wine and it was uh you say um even in
mathematics ignorance can be a virtue um
and i think about someone like nima is
just like this mathematical god you know
he thinks of himself as a mathematician
trained in toronto you know etc what um
what did you mean by that and can
somebody like nemo be considered to be
ignorant of mathematics it seems like
we have to like yeah you say that i
think nima
i i've i've had
loads of conversation with him
amazing physicist wonderful person
the key thing about him is he's a
physicist down to his uh down to his uh
to his toes and his fingers right that's
what he is he's absolutely driven to
understand uh the underlying order of
the universe basically right and uh
and there is absolutely you know his
passion he wears his passion on his
sleeve so to speak
now he
i
it's very important to uh when when
when
thinking about nema he doesn't do
mathematics for the sake of it right no
i i literally watched i got to know him
just off i mean just after he started at
the institute for advanced study when he
basically went in and i quote him now
like a graduate student into uh
uh into amplitude right scattering
amplitudes which is about you know
looking mathematically the very deepest
uh you know the scattering between
quarks and uh you know fundamental
particles and looking at that lowest
level of interaction describing them
using quantum mechanics and relativity
as he's always hanging on about quite
rightly now
he the the stuff that he's been driven
into it's been a glorious thing for me
as a friend of his to see you know he's
amazed to and he's had to work
incredibly hard to get into that
mathematics but he's not doing it to
show off right he's doing it because
he's being led there he's been pulled by
the nose so to speak right into it
and you ask him why he would say
i'm pretty sure ask him when you speak
to him i would be a great podcast right
he will say he's been driven there by
the fundamental principles at the heart
of quantum field theory and in
particular quantum mechanics and uh and
special relativity they have together
right and you know i remember asking him
once right are you sure are you really
saying that you could occasionally find
yourself veering off quantum mechanics
all that and you say yes that is true
okay
he said once he said to me i even did
that this morning right you can check it
line by line right
and it's though and that's where
incidentally um
that the miracle that we that we've
seen in this amplitude stuff that nemo
has done so brilliantly and of course he
has many brilliant collaborators
uh who who work with him in a very
creative way right that it's that
forcing together a quantum mechanically
that has given rise to these
mathematical directions right it's not
done because he just wants to show off
right it's because he feels it really is
relevant to nature
right and uh he's going to be a great
guest on your
your podcast but
again he wants to understand nature i
tell you a story about amplitude
somebody told me this and lima didn't
deny it and when he got into it and of
course he became a senior member of the
field very very fast somebody wanted to
do a uh make a collaboration with him
and nima said
i'll do that but if something comes up
at the lhc i'm dropping everything and
going into that
oh yeah now you see what i'm saying
there yeah it wasn't the case of him
leaving that discipline you see what i
mean right now he is uh and he he's been
uh very very gracious very um
very uh generous with his time and and
corresponding with me but he's clearly
deep involved in some and some very
significant work and he begs you know
kind of to to just just you know
forestall the conversation with me and
i've and i've of course i'm gonna give
him you know whatever time he needs and
it might actually work out that i get to
see him in person because i have a
meeting out there in a month or so and i
might actually get to do the interview
in person which would be really
spectacular
in my podcast we it's the only one we
split up because it was just are they
uneditable it was just so great the
level of the deep the depth of it and
the enthusiasm was so great oh it's
wonderful he's a you know he's
he's a wonderful ambassador for the
excitement the continued excitement of
physics
yeah and like when some people are
struggling to maintain that
yeah the person last person i want to
speak about before i have to run and
teach myself is just uh is kind of in
contrast to him as is gerard hoofed i
think is how you pronounce his name
i'm hoping to get him on the podcast as
well but he seems to be kind of the
freeman dyson like character you know
the old guard in some sense and uh maybe
i'll send him this episode to convince
him to come on but what are your
impressions of him and where he is he's
still quite active he has uh yeah he is
absolutely he's i really do believe he's
one of the great uh physicists yeah i
mean he really is i mean uh um and uh
you you have to take everything he says
seriously he certainly seems to be quite
skeptical of modern developments i think
it's fair to say now and you know he's
looking at new ways of formulating
quantum mechanics
uh which uh he i noticed how careful he
is to say the young people go and learn
it from the standard books i'm you know
but he he's obviously unhappy with the
formulation of it but no no no to huff
his absolutely another one is he's
basically like a duo in my time in
particle physics and that's uh sasha
pollyakov at princeton uh princeton
university those two were basically neck
and neck in many ways you know i mean
they are both absolutely brilliant
physicists
and it's a fame now that uh i mean that
we must have patronized them but you
know that they were our heroes in in the
70s you know they were just absolutely
teeming and of course the thing about
when i say to nemo so often he he really
doesn't like this incidentally
right he's don't you do you sometimes
miss that these two hoofs and and poglio
coughs and and weinberg's had actual
data right yeah i know this is
what people will say is that we're
getting data from the large capital
client and it's telling us something
it's our job right to interpret that
null result just like in a sense
einstein did with michaelson morley
right no result that is telling you
something
right
exactly right the most famous uh failed
experiment in history done at my alma
mater case western reserve university
that well it's again
it's
that history of that is endlessly
fascinating how can a null result right
be so powerful but we know it was
yep absolutely and again if we had
looked at falsification as our only
criterion how backwards things would
have been for mello i want to thank you
so much tell me is are you going to
resume your podcast uh it doesn't well i
i i made you at the moment i'm deep in
uh there's about 25 interviews there uh
yeah at the moment i'm deep in writing
the life of uh stephen stephen hawking
so we we will see but for the
congratulations on the job you're doing
you produce a wonderful
corpus of interviews so i'm very
grateful there's a lot a lot for us to
work through
yes thank you so much uh for coming on
the show for being a guest and uh for
inspiring us with your podcast
and for this wonderful book and for uh
the book on churchill dirac we'll have
you back and please do let me know as
soon as you're done with the book on
hawking i'd love to have you on i had
charles siphon for his book uh you may
have read it uh you may have seen the
interview it's quite critical i'd love
to have a discussion with you
and maybe we could have a friendly
debate with with uh charles that'll be
an interesting uh kind of uh uh pairing
to do if you're if you're up for it but
uh for now graham thank you so much for
spending so much of your valuable time
it's been a delight and a pleasure
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
if you enjoyed this video i know you'll
love my conversation with juan
malvescena as well as my other
conversations with physicists and
astronomers click here and don't forget
to subscribe leave a comment in the
comment section below do you think the
universe really speaks in numbers and if
we had another dirac another maxwell
would we recognize him or maybe her let
me know in the comments below
[Music]